Nik vial slams rumors he had an awkward  run-in with Andi Dorfman  just one day after a source told ET the  former Bachelorette contestant awkwardly  ran into his ex and e at the Badgley  Mischka Fashion Show in New York City  the reality star is speaking out  insisting he didn't even know she was  there Nick told ET on Wednesday quote we  didn't run into each other we weren't  even by each other as for that cryptic  tweet he sent out Sunday saying I miss  you so much it hurts sometimes  well apparently Nick is a huge scrubs  fan and just really missed his hometown  buddies I miss you so much it hurts  sometimes no Caitlin no Andi these days  nick is linked to model Kelly Thomas who  he hit the town with Tuesday night Nick  exclaimed they met through their  modeling agency and have known each  other for about a month they're not an  item yet but he did call her quote  awesome